- [Instructor] You've
probably seen plants,
either in your house or
if you go for a walk.
You've seen parts of the
plants twist and turn
in all sorts of directions.
And if you observe closely,
you'll see that oftentimes,
it looks like the plant is twisting
or turning towards the light.
And what we're gonna do in this video
is study that phenomenon
a little bit more.
So, in general, whenever we're
talking about an organism
twisting, or turning,
or changing direction
because of some type of external stimulus,
we call that tropism,
tropism.
And in the case of turning
or switching directions
because the external stimulus is light,
we would call that phototropism,
phototropism.
And phototropism is the general term
for any type of organism
turning direction,
or switching direction, or
moving in a certain direction
because of light.
And it could be moving towards the light,
or it could be moving away from the light.
Now, most of what we observe,
if you were to go see a forest,
you'll see that there
might be a patch in the,
or there might be an
opening in the canopy,
where the light is coming.
And you'll often see trees and plants
moving towards that light,
growing towards that light.
So, they are turning towards it.
This would be called
positive phototropism.
If for some reason, there
was some type of a plant
that was moving away from it,
that would be negative phototropism,
which is a little bit less,
or it's a lot less usual,
especially for the stem of a plant,
but we might talk about
that in future videos.
But what you would typically see
is positive phototropism like this.
And so, the question is,
is how does a plant do this?
What causes it to turn in
the direction of the light
in the case of positive phototropism?
Well, the key actor here
is a molecule called auxin.
It's auxin.
And auxin is phytohormone.
So, this is phyto,
phytohormone.
And
it's a fancy word for, this
is just a molecule involved
in the actual plant growth.
And so, what happens, let me
zoom in here on this plant,
let me zoom here on this plant.
And to be clear, we know how auxin acts.
But all of the mechanisms by
which the distribution of auxin
changes or how it gets
activated or deactivated
isn't completely understood.
And this is still an
area of active research.
But, what we know happens,
so let's say the light is coming from
that direction over here,
is for various reasons,
or for some reasons,
you have an increase
concentration of active auxin
on the side of the plant
away from the light.
So, you're going to have more auxin,
in this case since the light
is coming from the left,
you're gonna have more auxin on the right
than you are going to have on the left.
And what the auxin on the
right is causing to do,
it causes the cells
on the right side of this
stem right here to elongate.
So, if we were to zoom in,
so let me zoom in over here,
yeah, so let me take
that part of the plant.
And
if I were to zoom in,
if I were to zoom in, and if the cells,
I'm just gonna have a
two-dimensional view here.
Let's say on this side,
these are the cells.
And on this side, these
are the other cells.
Now, if we have more auxin,
more of this phytohormone
on the right-hand side, right over here,
than we have on the left,
what we know happens is
it causes the cell walls,
where there's more auxin, to
break down a little bit more.
And so, it allows those
cells to stretch or elongate.
And so, what's going to happen,
let me see if I can draw this,
is the cells on the right-hand
side are going to stretch,
are going to stretch, or elongate,
because of the auxin,
because they have more auxin in them
than the cells on the left-hand side.
And since these have
a higher concentration
of active auxin, they stretch.
And if the right-hand side gets longer
than the left-hand side,
what's going to happen?
Well, the plant is going
to bend to the left.
So, the plant is going to bend like that
because now the right-hand side
is longer than the left-hand side.
So, this is what we know about auxin.
It's a phytohormone
that whenever it is in
higher concentrations
and it's active, the cells
there are going to elongate,
which will cause this bending.
Now, the things that are
still being studied is
well, what caused there to be
a higher auxin concentration
on the right-hand side, and
all of the exact mechanisms
by which the auxin is actually acting.
We know things like it creates
a more acidic environment,
which helps break down the cell walls.
But how does it, you,
how do you have a higher
concentration here on the right?
Well, in many plants studied,
it's actually the blue light
that causes the sensitivity.
So, I drew this as yellow,
but really I should
draw this as blue light
that causes the sensitivity.
Although, it's not always blue light.
It could be red light.
It could be other frequencies of light.
And the various theories,
and it might be some combination of it,
is when you have the light
on one side of the plant,
that it causes, one possibility is
maybe it causes the auxin to migrate
from the side with the light
to the side that has less light.
Another possibility is if
the auxin is migrating down
from the top of the stem,
that it might cause more to migrate
where there is less light
than when there is more light.
There is other possibilities,
that somehow the light
deactivates the auxin on the left,
or maybe allows less auxin to be produced
than what would happen on the right.
So, these are all possibilities.
And this is what's
interesting about science
is that there's always
more for us to understand.
But what we do know
is that this type of
positive phototropism,
which you will often in the forest
or you'll even see it on a house plant,
if you put it next to a window,
it'll bend towards the window,
or it'll often bend towards the window.
It's caused, the key actor here is auxin
and the distribution of auxin
changing in response to the light,
and that the auxin distribution increases
on the side away from the light
when you have positive phototropism.
Now, this picture here
looks like this might be phototropism,
but this is actual a mutant plant
that actually is lacking auxin.
So, it's growing in all
sorts of random directions,
but it's just interesting to look at.